[Musik]
[Applaus]
viel grün viel genuss und ganz viel geld
wovon hier wohl die rede ist ganz genau
meine liegen wir sogar politik zuschauer
von irland die grüne insel ist eines der
reichsten länder der welt und hat in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten ein echtes
wirtschaftswunder hingelegt wenn von
euch jemand beruflich mit zu tun hat
werdet ihr wissen dass fast alle
hightech unternehmen sehr große
standorte und ihre europazentrale in
irland haben angefangen von apple über
facebook google oder microsoft aber eher
land ist auch für westliche verhältnisse
wirklich wohlhabend es ist sogar reicher
als die schweiz wenn man das
bruttoinlandsprodukt pro kopf nimmt laut
edf wird dieses in diesem jahr bei
schätzungsweise umgerechnet rund
124.000 us-dollar liegen im vergleich zu
knapp 85.000 us-dollar bei den
schweizern in europa übertreffen irland
in dieser kategorie nur die kleinstadt
monaco liechtenstein und luxemburg aber
nicht nur das obwohl irland schon
verdammt reich und entwickelt ist wächst
es seit über einem jahrzehnt so schnell
wie ein schwellenland erinnert ihr euch
noch an 2020 als corona kam es war das
jahr in dem praktisch jedes land der
welt in eine rezession rutschte aber
nicht so ireland das bip der iren stieg
2020 sogar um 5,8 prozent solche zahlen
kennt man nur aus ländern wie china oder
vietnam
das hat zunächst sogar viele
wirtschaftswissenschaftler überrascht
die vor allem während der finanzkrise
von 2008 eine zusammenbruch der irischen
wirtschaft vorhersagten einer von ihnen
war immerhin nobelpreisträger paul
krugman und dann im jahr 2015
erwirtschaftete irland ein wachstum beim
bip von sage und schreibe 25 prozent und
wie viele bereits annehmen hat diese
zahl einen kleinen haken welche genau da
wird am ende dieses videos genau
verstehen thorsten die frage ist was
macht irland so wohlhabend
[Musik]
viele von euch denken jetzt vielleicht
an niedrige steuersätze was sonst und
tatsächlich hat irland eine der
niedrigsten unternehmenssteuersätze der
welt das hat sehr wohl dazu beigetragen
die großen unternehmen dieser welt ins
land zu locken aber schaut euch mal
diese nachricht an
die republik irland erfüllt den
körperschaftsteuersatz auf 15 prozent
könnte diese steuererhöhungen sie tritt
2023 in kraft vielleicht das ende des
irischen wirtschaftswunders betreten
oder ist er lang vielleicht viel mehr
als nur ein steuerparadies warum genau
ist das land zu reich und warum wachsen
sie weiter als wären sie ein
schwellenland heute werden wir all diese
fragen natürlich beantworten und zwar
gleich nach einem kleinen selber
hinweist von unserem sponsor aufschlag
der dieses video möglich gemacht hat
server vpn ist ein wirklich sicheres vpn
welches zum beispiel keinerlei
verbindungsdaten mit lockt natürlich
kann ein virtual private network vpn 1
nicht vor allen gefahren schützen die
invest lauern man muss nach wie vor
umsicht walten lassen und wissen was man
tut aber es stellt hierfür werkzeuge mit
gleich mehreren vorteilen bereit zum ein
erschwertes in kombination mit anderen
vorkehrungen eure aktionen messen
nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit hilfe
verschiedener sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so zum beispiel eure anonymität in
messel zb mit den integrierten cleanbag
dass alle cookies und pop-ups blockt
weiterer vorteil eines problem ist dass
ihr so tun können als wärt ihr an einem
anderen ort so könnt ihr zum beispiel
auf websites und internet dienste
zugreifen in dem land in dem er dessen
wären ob daran oder im urlaub damit
schlag der zensur und videoblog in ein
schnippchen verflixt und andere
streaming diese die ihre inhalte nur in
den usa anbieten von europa ausnutzen
oder deutsches internet fernsehen im
ausland cook mit zu auf schott kein
problem aber das ist noch lange nicht
alles denn mit nur einem server konnte
könnt ihr wirklich alle eure endgeräte
im vpn registrieren handys notebooks
oder sogar euren smart tvs so und wenn
ihr den rabattcode politik.de angeht
bekommt ihr fonds auch noch einen rabatt
in höhe von 83 prozent und in den ersten
drei monate gratis dazu den links zu
diesen angebot findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesen video also
nichts wie los besorgt als forscher und
damit auch gleichzeitig uns finanziell
unter die arme das könnt ihr übrigens
auch direkt mit hilfe des pk spenden
links den ich auf ebenfalls gegen die
beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind euch
für jede unterstützung dankbar denn
damit hätten wir uns auch in zukunft
noch mehr und noch bessere videos zu
liefern so und nun lasst uns die das
schnell auf die grüne insel zurückkehren
und unsere fragen die auch mit hilfe
eines kurzen blick in die geschichte
beantworten
[Musik]
ab nach boston
für amerikanische stadt boston haben die
iren eine ganz besondere beziehung viele
iren sind in den vergangenen
jahrhunderten genau dorthin ausgewandert
berühmt ist die stadt auch für einen
typisch irischen feiertag der in saint
patrick's day und das zugehörige
festival aber auch in new york oder
chicago ist die irische und ihre
ständige community noch immer sehr groß
und jedes jahr am 17 märz wird man dort
ganz grün vor stolz tatsächlich leben in
den usa mehr ihre ständige menschen als
in irland selbst wirft man einen blick
auf diese tabelle
hier könnt ihr sehen wie die iren in
irland selbst seit dem neunzehnten
jahrhundert immer weniger wurden schon
vor der unabhängigkeit vom vereinigten
königreich setzte diese entvölkerung ein
muss dafür gibt es eine erklärung
armut macht euch mal folgendes klar
ireland gehörte zum britischen empire
der damals führenden weltmacht den 07
jahrhundert mit der industriellen
revolution die welt veränderte und
gleichzeitig verrückten dort
millionenfach die menschen weil sie
nichts zu essen hatten
[Musik]
zugegeben die beziehungen zu london war
voller spannungen und von aufständen
geprägt die iren waren bürger zweiter
klasse die entweder verhungerten
auswanderten oder aufständen für ihre
unabhängigkeit kämpfen und diese
unabhängigkeit erreichen sie 1937 und
zwar erst nach einem blutigen
bürgerkrieg die republik irland hatte
jetzt ihre eigene verfassung
ausgearbeitet war eigenständig und
anerkannt aber immer noch bettelarm aber
warum eigentlich die antwort liegt mal
wieder in der politik nach seiner
unabhängigkeitserklärung entschied sich
irland nämlich für ein autarkes
wirtschaftsmodell dies geschah auch
angesichts der weltweiten
wirtschaftskrise den 1930 er jahre lang
wusste wirtschaft nicht unabhängig sein
und nichts aus dem ausland importieren
müssen wir haben über den ganz ähnlich
gelagerten fall aus dieser zeit
argentinien in einem eigenen video
berichtet dass es euch verlinken werde
schon dort konnte man sehen eine
selbstversorgung funktioniert selten und
erst recht nicht bei einer insel mit
damals weniger als vier millionen
menschen und kaum industrie so gab es
dann keinen nennenswerten import mehr
aber man war nach wie vor führt im
export von genau ihren die kam nach wie
vor in rauen mengen in boston an
das änderte sich jedoch im jahr 1959 mit
diesen herrn thomas kelly dem damaligen
premierminister von irland er versuchte
die irische wirtschaft zu liberalisieren
und warum sage ich versuchte nun weil
der gute alte mister o kelly nur einige
teile des rezepts befolgt hat dennoch im
jahr 1959 schuf er die erste moderne
freihandelszone welt in der nähe des
flughafens kennen die schellen freetown
auf diese weise kamen die ersten
ausländischen unternehmen ins land
angelockt von niedrigen steuersätzen ein
vorreiter war zum beispiel apple 1980
gründete apple sein europa hauptsitz in
irischen cork und es handelt es sich
übrigens um die erste apple
niederlassung außerhalb der usa doch
nichts davon hat dass neben der iren
wirklich verbessert ganz im gegenteil
die ausländischen unternehmen siedelten
meist nur ihre steuer sitzt quasi als
briefkastenfirma in gegenden wie
schellen an mehr nicht mit anderen
worten in den ersten büros von apple
oder hewlett-packard war nur ein paar
buchhalter beschäftigt wenn überhaupt
und es gab in jenen jahren in irland
nach wie vor kaum industrie in der viele
iren arbeit gefunden hätten gleichzeitig
überschwemmten ausländische produkte den
markt immerhin liege jetzt in porto zu
aber die iren waren immer noch arm
zumindest für westliche verhältnisse
1987 lag die arbeitslosenquote in irland
bei 17 prozent die löhne lagen bei nur
einem drittel des britischen den großen
und irland war immer noch führend bei
einer bestimmten exportgut den iren
selbst anders ausgedrückt egal wie ihre
land mit niedrigen steuersätzen lockte
die ihren kunden immer noch nicht reich
werden sie konnten noch kein eigenes
vermögen durch arbeit erwirtschaften und
wanderten nach wie vor aus wie aber
wurde er nun zu jenem keltischen tiger
den wir heute kennen naja not macht eben
nicht nur erfinderisch sondern auch
wirtschaftsliberale schauen wir uns das
doch mal an
was würden des keltischen tigers
die frage der frage für irland in den
80er jahren war was müsste geschehen
damit den multinationalen unternehmen im
land endlich auch irischen mitarbeiter
einstellen abgesehen von
freihandelszonen wie shannon lacht noch
die listen zum beispiel sollten
arbeitnehmer bis zu 60 prozent
einkommenssteuer mit ausnahme der
freihandelszone zeiten unternehmen noch
immer über 40 prozent unternehmensteuer
und die arbeitsgesetze waren so streng
dass einstellungen und entlassungen zu
einem wahren bürokratischen albtraum
worden mit dem sonst in anderen
sächsischen ländern so bekannten
unflexiblen hire and fire prinzip hatte
irland praktisch nichts am hut und dann
kam 1987 premierminister scharf er
leitete eine echte liberalisierung und
steuersenkungen ein die ihr land
brauchte und siehe da die ergebnisse
ließen nicht lange auf sich warten
plötzlich las man in den irischen medien
immer wieder nachrichten wie diese
dass hewlett packard werk in lyss lab
stellt bis zum jahr 2000 2000 menschen
ein ab mitte der 1990 er jahre nahm das
land ordentlich fahrt auf wenn du nur
eines jahrzehnts haben es die historisch
immer weit hinterherhinken ihren
geschafft ihre englischen nachbarn bei
durchschnittslöhnen sogar zu übertreffen
[Musik]
jetzt wuchs das bip mit rund 6 prozent
pro jahr das waren wachstumsraten wie
bei den asiatischen tigerstaaten nur war
es der keltische tiger der da brüllte
und jetzt kamen sie auf alle richtig im
land an dell intel und microsoft
eröffneten standorte in irland das land
wurde zu einem zentrum der hightech
industrie und auch irische unternehmen
erlangten weltruhm ryanair flug schon
mitte der 80er jahre auf den britischen
inseln aber den 90ern revolutionierte es
die luftfahrtbranche mit seinem
billigflug modell ab den 2000er jahren
legte primark eine massive expansion auf
dem ganzen kontinent hin nachdem die
billig modekette vorher ein 30-jähriges
schatten dasein in irland und england
geführt hatte jetzt statt irland für
neue erfolgreiche geschäftskonzepte
hightech und big business und endlich
kamen menschen nach irland um dort
besser zu leben zb die osteuropäer aber
sogar viele iren kehrten zurück alle
wollten am neuen wohlstand teilhaben und
banken vergaben auch fleißig kredite vor
allem für immobilien irland wurde zum
traumland eines jeden libertären wo die
wirtschaft einfach rund liegt und ein
freier markt wunderbar funktionierte
alles mithilfe niedriger steuersätze und
ohne große staatliche einflüsse vor eine
laxe regulierung profitierten auch die
banken vor allem mit us banken machte
man gute geschäfte in irland bis zur
finanzkrise 2008 dagegen die partie zu
ende und in ihren kam die fette rechnung
dafür ins haus geflattert
der domino effekt
die irischen geldinstitute waren in eine
geradezu sucht artige abhängigkeit von
us banken geraten von denen sie 2008
dann auch mit nach unten gerissen wurden
die summe der damals ausstehenden
kredite und hypotheken darlehen soll
etwa das vierfache des irischen bip
betragen haben dh dass alle ihren vier
jahre lang theoretisch nur für die
rückzahlung der schulden hätten arbeiten
müssen ohne auch nur einen cent davon
für essen oder kleidung übrig zu haben
natürlich konnten einen solchen
schuldenberg weder die irischen banken
verdauen noch die irische wirtschaft
sieht sich an
hier könnt ihr sehen wie irland in eine
rezession rutschte die noch tiefer war
als die in den usa die arbeitslosenquote
schnellte 2010 auf 13 prozent hoch der
irische staat versuchte seine banken zu
stützen und verschuldete sich dadurch
immer mehr die ratingagenturen stuften
die kreditwürdigkeit des landes immer
weiter ab sogar der zahlungsausfall
droht und was glaubt ihr dass ihr land
getan hat um den zusammenbruch seiner
wirtschaft wo die staatspleite zu
verhindern
ganz genau es hat die eu um hilfe
gebeten
[Musik]
die europäische union oder
internationale währungsfonds haben
irland mit einem darlehen von insgesamt
67 5 milliarden euro ausgeholfen das
entsprach etwa 40 prozent des bip des
landes darlehen heißt jedoch irgendwann
muss man dieses geld auch zurückzahlen
für ihre land hieß das jetzt erst einmal
sparen sparen und nochmals sparen und im
polizeijargon nennt man das aus der ets
politik irland hat zum beispiel die
mehrwertsteuer erhöht und die
öffentlichen ausgaben in allen bereichen
gesenkt die gehälter der beamten worden
und 14 prozent gekürzt und gleichzeitig
viele gebühren und abgaben erhöht
daraufhin kam es zu protesten im ganzen
land weil man für banken und nicht
bluten wollte und wie viele experten
waren das typische ich habe es euch ja
gesagt momente wie zum beispiel hier der
des ökonomen paul krugman im jahr 2010
[Musik]
irland befindet sich nun im dritten jahr
der sparmaßnahmen und das vertrauen
schwindet immer weiter und man muss sich
fragen wann vernünftige menschen endlich
erkennen dass es schlimmer als es
verbrechen ist die bevölkerung für die
sünden der banker zu bestrafen es ist
ein fehler paul krugman 2010 in der new
york times aber war es wirklich ein
fehler merkt euch dieses zitat aus dem
jahr 2010 gut denn nur zwei jahre später
gelingt der irischen wirtschaft ein
fulminantes comeback darf man einen
blick
[Musik]
wie ihr sehen könnt hat sich irland
nicht nur von der krise erholt ist wurde
gemessen am bip pro kopf reicher als die
usa selbst und was für ein sprung
gemacht der chart zwischen 2014 und s16
das ist die zeit in dem irland alle
rekorde brach und ein bip um ganze 25
prozent steigerte aber wie zum teufel
haben sie das eigentlich geschafft wurde
da nicht vielleicht geschummelt nun
haltet euch fest denn das alles sehen
uns jetzt lieber mal etwas genauer an
und ich kann euch schon verraten hier
wird erst so richtig spannend
[Musik]
wenn das die die nicht so recht passt
stellt euch nur mal paul krugmans
gesicht vor erhielt bankenrettung und
sparpolitik für einen fehler und
prophezeite irland gar den
wirtschaftlichen zusammenbruch aber
dieser trat nie ein innerhalb weniger
jahre hat irland die schuldenkrise
überwunden und ist zum wachstum
zurückgekehrt als gäbe es kein morgen
das ganze aber einfach nur als wachstum
zu bezeichnen wäre die untertreibung des
jahrhunderts die richtigen worte hierfür
sind brutaler boom und wirtschaftswunder
eine wachstumsrate von 25 prozent das
kleine irland schreibt damit
wirtschaftsgeschichte also sorry china
du bist echt langweilig geworden aber
was glaubt ihr hat der gute alte puppen
getan als er davon gehört hat nun als
gewissenhafter wissenschaftler geht mal
so einer sache doch auf den grund und
das hat er auch getan seht euch an
roger kong economic saarland meldet 26
prozent wachstum und das ergibt keinen
sinn was hat das mit dem bip zu tun
krugman stadt eine bemerkenswerte
anomalie der anstieg um mehr ist und 20
prozent des bip daher das große player
der weltwirtschaft vor allem apple ihre
gewinne nach irland verlagert haben um
von den niedrigen steuersätzen zu
profitieren allein apple hat zwischen
2010 und 2014 und 149 milliarden
us-dollar nach irland transferiert das
ist ein wahrer geldregen vor allem für
ein kleines land wie irland mit einem
bip das jetzt im jahr 2022 bei 418
milliarden euro liegt mit anderen worten
die statistik spiegelt nicht die
realität wider das ganze geld von apple
ist nicht in die irische wirtschaft
geflossen und schon gar nicht dort
erwirtschaftet worden in wirklichkeit
handelt es sich nur um eine zahl in
einem geschäftsbericht und die steuer-
und finanzexperten von apple waren nicht
die einzigen die irland rein virtuell
mit geld übergossen haben
laut angaben des edf sind 60 prozent der
ausländischen investitionen in irland
nichts als zahlen auf dem papier krugman
nannte dies lap record kölner max j
records sind diese kobold ähnlichen
wesen aus der irischen mythologie
anders ausgedrückt die klassische
wirtschaftsstatistik funktioniert für
irland einfach nicht mehr
die statistischen verzerrungen sind
inzwischen so groß dass sie die
herkömmliche verwendung des britischen
bip lächerlich machen
[Applaus]
über die probleme mit der aussagekraft
des dgb und alle möglichen schummeleien
damit haben sie auch schon mal in einem
video über die hochinteressante
geschichte der gefälschten
wirtschaftsdaten chinas erzählt ich
werde euch dieses video natürlich
verlinken damit ihr es euch später
ansehen könnt tatsächlich verwendet
irland mittlerweile eine modifizierte
rechnung des bip um seine
wirtschaftskraft anständig zu messen man
versucht die virtuellen gewinne
herauszurechnen etwas gutes hatte dass
phänomene leprechaun economics dennoch
es hat dazu beigetragen dass die
steuertricks öffentlich geworden sind
der in zahlreiche große vor allem
us-unternehmen haben die laxen
steuergesetze in irland genutzt um
steuer modelle zu entwickeln mit denen
sie unanständig wenig steuern zahlen
mussten seit 2010 haben die eu und die
vereinigten staaten mehrere maßnahmen
und gesetze verabschiedet derartige
winken vermögensverschiebungen zu
verhindern und auch irlands regierung
hat sich bereits verpflichtet steuern zu
erhöhen
die republik irland erhöht den
körperschaftsteuersatz auf 15 prozent
dort heißt die ich nur dass airlines
reichtum vollkommen aktuell ist nichts
weiter als buchhalter tricks und clevere
steuersparmodelle ist das irische
wirtschaftswunder vorbei und werden die
iren bald wieder in scharen aus sondern
auch gepasst
made in arbeit
nein der erfolg der insel beruhte nicht
nur auf niedrigen steuern wenn man
einfach nur die steuersenkung müsste um
damit automatisch wohlstand zu schaffen
würden in andorra nur millionäre leben
und liberia wäre ein wohlhabendes land
tatsächlich sind viele steuerparadiese
jeder bettelarme land hat es hingegen
geschafft das weltbekannte unternehmen
sich tatsächlich mit ihrem operativen
geschäft in land niederlassen und dort
mitarbeiter einstellen darüber hinaus
ist ist in ihren gelungen eigene
unternehmen zu gründen die bereits groß
und konkurrenzfähig sind oder wie im
fall ryanair die konkurrenz das fürchten
gelehrt haben die airline gilt als eine
der diskutierten firmen der
wirtschaftsgeschichte bleiben wir mal
bei der luftfahrt vielleicht überrascht
ist euch aber ihr land ist heute ein
hauptzentrum der modernen airline
industrie macht euch diese namen aircap
ge capital aviation services und apollo
noch nie davon gehört nun dies die
titanen des flugzeug leasing
irland ist führend in der leasingbranche
für verkehrsflugzeuge die meisten
kommerziellen airlines der welt nicht
selbst eigentümer ihrer flugzeugflotte
ließen die flieger lieber bei einer
leasingfirma das macht die flexibler und
finanziell robuster und so stammen 22
prozent der weltweit liegenden
passagierflugzeugs worte von irischen
unternehmen und was ist mit software
auch google facebook oder microsoft
haben nicht mehr nur ihre steuer sitzend
her land allein im softwaresektor sind
auf der grünen insel heute über 24.000
menschen beschäftigt mit der kerry group
besitzt irland einen weltmarktführer für
nahrungsmittelzusätze grund lebensmittel
der speichermedien riese seagate
technology hat 2010 seinen globalen
hauptsitz nach dublin verlegt der 50
milliarden umsatz beratungs gigant
accenture tat dies bereits ein jahr
zuvor und da 30 milliarden dollar
schwere medizintechnikhersteller
medtronic im jahr 2007 mit anderen
worten irlands wirtschaft ist
diversifiziert und konkurrenzfähig das
land nimmt einen spitzenplatz in europa
ein aber ist wirklich alles so rosig auf
der insel dies scheint nun nicht ganz
die immobilienkrise wird über die
politische zukunft irlands entscheiden
das ist die kehrseite des
wirtschaftlichen erfolgs ihre land
exportiert keine arbeitskräfte mehr ganz
im gegenteil städte die dublin und cork
zehn menschen von überall her an wohnung
wird knapp preise und mieten steigen
exorbitant dies ist sicher kein
geringfügiges problem angesichts von
protesten die ist bereits gegen die
steigenden mieten und gegen die massive
gentrifizierung gibt eine wohnung zu
finden egal ob zum kauf oder zur miete
ist zum lotteriespiel oder er so
spießrutenlauf geworden viele iren
können sich ihr eigenes land einfach
nicht mehr leisten es ist die
unmenschliche seite des booms aber wie
können solche probleme gelöst werden die
ja nicht nur in irland auftreten und
noch wichtiger welche lehren können
andere länder aus dem irischen modells
welche auswirkungen könnte der ukraine
krieg und seine folgen auf
volkswirtschaften wie irland haben
schreibt uns doch im kommentarbereich
was eure meinung hierzu ist und falls
dieses video interessant für euch war
ihr vielleicht auch etwas aber gelernt
habe vergesst bitte nicht diese politik
zu leiten und auch zu abonnieren und
selbst wenn ihr schon ein aha denkt
bitte daran dass erst das glücklichen
ein richtiges abo darstellt ich danke
euch dafür macht es gut und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]